سال الناس في مصر مشاهدينا من المسؤول عن
سعاده المراه لنرى الاجابه
انا شايفه ان الحاجه الاساسيه اللي بتسعد
المراه لو في حب حقيقي في حياتها والحاجه
التانيه بقى الاكل دي اهم حاجه طول ما هي
حاسه بالامان هي مرضيه وهي دي سعادتها
يعني النجاح ممكن بيطور منها ويخليها
سعيده وراك وسط المجتمع شايفه الاول
المسؤول عن ساعات المراه هي الفلوس بتقدر
تشتري اي حاجه هي عايزاها عامه
امشي تكون هي تقنع باي باي ظروف هي موضوع
فيها وترضى والرضا يعني اي حد يجيب لها
شيكولاته هتبقى مبسوطه جدا يعني فدي سر
سعاده المراه في الشيكولاته يعني
انا ممكن اسعد نفسي مفيش حاجه معينه يعني
ممكن انزل اخرج نفسي
اروحلهاش
اكل الاكل اللي انا بحبه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات